[Music]
foreign
this is Sky News at 10 live from
Edinburgh where a new leader has been
announced
Hamza Yusuf is to be Scotland's new
first Minister after becoming the new
leader of the SNP
people of Scotland need Independence now
more than ever before and we will be the
generation that delivers Independence
for Scotland
I would love to be independent
but this country's got to pay its way
we look at what it means for the debate
around Scottish independence
also coming up on Sky News at 10 a woman
shoots dead three children and three
adults at a school in Nashville
Tennessee
Prince Harry's lawyers accused the
Publishers of the Daily Mail of tapping
and taping the royal couple as the Duke
attends a hearing at the high court
Israel's prime minister postpones
Judiciary reform after tens of thousands
of people joined demonstrations on the
streets
130 000 public service members to walk
out in an all-out strike on the 28th of
April and Gwyneth Paltrow back in court
with the man suing the actor over a ski
accident describing hearing screams like
someone was out of control
I heard something I've never heard of
the ski resort and that was a blood
curdling scream
just I can't do it
and then
boom
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello good evening live from Hollywood
the home of the Scottish parliament in
Edinburgh Hamza Yusuf is now the leader
of the Scottish national party and after
a vote in Hollywood tomorrow is expected
to be announced as the new first
minister of Scotland the leadership race
which has at times been a bitter contest
damaging for the SNP was triggered by
the resignation of Nicholas sturgeon a
dominant figure in Scottish politics for
nearly a decade in a moment we'll take a
look at the issues facing Scotland's
first Minister and what this result
means for the Scottish independence
debate but first our Scotland
correspondent Connor Gillis has
tonight's first report which does
contain flash photography
how are your feeling
the honest answer the man in the middle
will be Scotland's next first Minister
it comes the Yusuf selective as the new
SMP leader I have been given the results
of the party leader election 2023
moments before the room was on a knife
edge cameras fixed on candidates
some struggling more than others to
disguise their displeasure
I therefore declare I'm the Yusuf Julie
elected as the Scottish national party
leader
congratulations
and just as I will lead the SNP in the
interests of all party members
not just those who voted for me so I
will aim to lead Scotland in the
interests of all of our citizens
whatever your political allegiance The
polls were suggesting throughout the
contest that you of the three candidates
were the most incompetent weak and
untrustworthy how are you going to turn
that around I've got every confidence
not just my own ability but frankly the
ability of the exceptional sap team the
I'm a Democrat members have made their
views known and this was a bruising
battle for the SMP candidates squabbling
in public it will though go down in the
history books Yusuf the first Muslim
leader of any major UK party I think
it's been a great contest which has
created space for robust
comes the use of trustworthy
I believe so yes I give him my sport
would you serve in his cabinet um we'll
wait to see if he offers me a job the
nation watched the new chapter unfold
observing their decision makers edging
closer to office I was disappointed to
get the Nigerian I thought the woman was
uh
you know
the things you might have lost a few
votes with Commandments saying one or
two things I think the guy is going to
be okay his speech just now we're not
simply be quite positive so I'll just
take a go with the floor and hopefully
things will improve for Scotland yusuf's
Victory here in Edinburgh was extremely
narrow he now needs to Pivot his
position to appeal to The Wider public
and when it comes to policies he's for
making it easier to change gender
legislation Westminster is currently
blocking Yusuf has not ruled out taking
the issue to courts putting him in a
constitutional Clash potentially from
day one the real job of governing now
begins as Hollywood votes for its new
first Minister on Tuesday in a country
divided on its political path Conor
Gillis Sky News Edinburgh
of getting more than 26 000 votes and 52
percent of the vote K Forbes received
nearly 24 000 votes and 48 percent a
third candidate Ash Regan was knocked
out in the first round of the voting
Hamza Yusuf will be the youngest ever
first Minister and the first Muslim
leader as Conor was saying in his
campaign he promised to Champion
Independence for Scotland making it he
says his top priority
he said he'd make Scotland an
international leader in human rights by
pushing forward the Scottish
government's Human Rights bill
he also promised to ban conversion
therapy and embed LGBT rights into an
independent Scotland's Constitution
well Mr yusuf's Victory may have been a
relief for the SNP but is also an
opportunity for Scotland's opposition
parties to renew their arguments for
maintaining the union and a platform to
make gains at the next general election
a political correspondent Joe Pike
reports from Scottish Labor's top Target
seat East Lothian awarding this report
contains flash photography
like much of Scotland's political
Landscape East Lothian was labor for
decades in Preston pans they used to
mine coal to heat homes
now energy costs are so high this
project has been launched to offer older
people a warm room and a hot drink and
everyone has a view on Independence it
sounds good in theory I would love to be
independent
but this country's got to pay its way
and there isn't enough people
and do you want Scotland to be
independent
Yeah by law
poverty levels are a concern here yet
most vote based on their view of
Scotland's constitutional future
the 2014 Independence referendum
transformed Scottish politics and while
the SMP may have been the losers the
dream shall never die within months they
were winning at the 2015 general
election as the pro UK vote split three
ways most pro-independent Scots backed
the SMP and it will not be business as
usual the Nationalist 156 of Scotland's
59 seats I will also table my
resignation as leader of the Scottish
labor party labor went from 41 to 1. for
that structural Advantage has kept the
SMP on winning form but will it last if
that relationship between whether you
support Independence or the union and
how you vote in the election if that
starts to break down
um then that will be primarily of course
to Labor's advantage
Nicholas sturgeon's departure was always
going to be a game changer for Scottish
labor party sources argue between 10 and
20 Westminster seats like this one are
now in play they could help kierstama
get into Downing Street but rebuilding a
battered party takes time as one labor
strategist explained their ground
operation off the border is now
practically non-existent
you're okay to stand up let's come
standing Mr Yousaf has spent the last
two years running Scotland's struggling
Health Service
everyone here has experience of the NHS
yet so far the new SMP leader doesn't
seem to have made much of an impression
what do you think of Hamza Yousaf
um
been interested in smp's policies
raising his profile will be easy
securing a path to leaving the UK may
not after decades in politics Nicholas
surgeon now has her independence
achieving that for Scotland will be a
lot more difficult Joe Pike Sky News
East Lothian
well Scotland correspondent colleague is
with me now and Connor's been a busy day
hasn't it and and that result was a lot
closer than I think a lot of people
thought it would be yeah that win for
Hamza Yusuf was wafer thin a wafer thin
majority for the new SMP leader let's
remember as well let's put this into
context tens of thousands of SMP
supporters here in Scotland voted for
change they voted for Cape Forbes they
didn't think that continuity would cut
it in this contest so he has an uphill
battle when it comes to reuniting a
party that has become pretty fractured
over the course of the last couple of
weeks and he has got an enormous entree
of issues to deal with domestic policies
here in Scotland also how will he square
that Circle of dealing with the
impatient YES Movement the independence
movement that is waiting with baited
breath for that independent vote that
may or may not be happening anytime soon
it's something that comes the use of
will be wanting to prioritize as well
the focus shifts to that building
tomorrow morning where we will get more
developments on the vote the
confirmatory vote for Hamza Yusuf who is
more than likely due to become
Scotland's next first Minister tomorrow
cool thanks very much
so as Connor says it's out with the old
and in with the new and there is a sense
perhaps of a new generation taking over
inside the SMP taking the reins and your
top team is going to have to be
established and of course let's not
forget that this is a party still in
some disarray and for a wider Scotland
the new leader needs to address the cost
of living and issues with the NHS but
above all of that there is that Vex
question of Scottish independence
hovering perhaps like banquo's ghost
what will the new snp's relationship be
with Westminster and what does Hamza
yusuf's a session mean for the union
itself
Anna back to you
Jane thank you three students and three
adults have been killed at a private
Christian school in Nashville Tennessee
in the last few minutes the victim's
names have been released the children
were all nine years old they were Evelyn
Dickhouse Holly Scruggs and William
Kinney the adults all in their 60s were
named as Cynthia Peake Catherine Kuntz
and Mike Hill authorities said the
suspect was a former student of the
school called Audrey Hale wielding two
assault style rifles and a pistol Sky's
U.S correspondent James Matthews has
this report
outside the Covenant School in Nashville
this was the evacuation of its pupils
children were escorted by police into
the arms of families who rushed to a
schoolgate reunion
behind them they are scene of mass
murder
an incident lasting 14 minutes a 28 year
old woman killed three children and
three adults
while the shooting ensued pupils and
staff hid where they could my mom said
there was a shooter she said she was
hiding in the closet and that they were
shooting all over and that
they had potentially tried to get into a
room and just that she like loved us and
that they could just hear shooting like
all over the school
the killer was on with two assault
rifles a pistol was also found at the
scene she was shot dead by armed
officers on the second story of the
building
in the wake of the shooting this was the
scene at a property close to the school
officers looking into the perpetrators
background blew open the door and
conducted a search inside
from my initial findings is that at one
point she was a student at that school
but unsure what year all of that but
that's what I've been told so far
as a nation digested details of the
atrocity its president responded with a
repeated call for a ban on assault
weapons
it's heartbreaking a family's worst
nightmare
and I want to commend the police who
report responded incredibly swiftly
within minutes and the danger
we're monitoring the situation really
closely Ben as you know and we have to
do more to stop gun violence it's
ripping our communities apart ripping a
soul this nation ripping at the very
soul of the nation
if his words reflect a revolution Rich
large so the pictures from Nashville
who smoke children among the victims of
U.S gun violence the latest but almost
certainly not the last James Matthews
Sky News in Washington
Prince Harry was in London today as he
made a surprise visit to the high court
the prince along with Sir Elton John
Sadie Frost and Liz Hurley are suing
Associated newspapers the Publishers of
the Daily Mail and mail on Sunday the
Duke listened and took notes in court as
lawyers for the mail laid out their case
on why it should be thrown out of court
before going to trial Katie Spencer
reports now from the high court
his arrival was unexpected for the Duke
of Sussex fully aware of what makes
headlines as he goes to battle with the
British tabloid press not required to
take the stand but clearly want him to
be seen of making a stand as the
Publishers of the mail fight to have the
case thrown out before it goes to trial
joining him in person in court part of
the joint action the actress Sadie Frost
and Sir Elton John and his Husband David
furnish who allege Associated newspapers
bugged their home taped private
conversations and published their first
child's birth certificate before the
singer had even seen it actress was
Hurley claiming her phone was hacked and
home was bugged with a microphone taped
to her window and that her then
boyfriend Hugh Grant's Car was bugged
Prince Harry and his fellow complainants
this is personal allegations dating back
to 1993 through to as recently as 2018
of the criminal use of private
investigators to obtain medical
financial and phone records allegations
categorically denied by Associated
newspapers who say they'll vigorously
contest the claims
Adrian Beltrami Casey for the male
emphasizing the historical nature of the
allegations that the court should not
hesitate to dismiss these stale claims
at an early stage if you have a
defendant with deep enough pockets they
can make good enough offers to transfer
the costs and the risk of that which is
millions onto a claim now Prince Harry
has said he's not going to settle so
that suggests that he's prepared to take
the chance
whether or not the case goes any further
Prince Harry apparently harnessing his
star power to draw attention to what
happens here the poster boy if you will
for privacy in just one of a number of
court cases is involved with that will
be heard in the coming months Katie
Spencer's Sky News
there'll be more clashes between police
and demonstrators in Israel tonight
Israel's prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has delayed controversial
plans to reform the country's Judiciary
after protests and Strikes threatened to
paralyze Israeli Society while speaking
this evening Mr Netanyahu said he would
take a time out to find a solution but
attacked what he called an extremist
minority ready to divide the country
so let's take a look then at how we got
to these protests seen today in November
2019 Benjamin Netanyahu was charged with
fraud and accepting bribes charges that
he has always denied in 2021 Netanyahu
was ousted as prime minister by a
coalition of liberal right-wing and Arab
parties with naftali Bennett and then
yeah lapid alternating as prime minister
Israel then held its fifth election in a
four-year period in November 2022
Netanyahu was re-elected bolstered by a
coalition of religious and far-right
parties in January netanyahu's Justice
Minister announced plans to give
expanded power to the government to veto
Supreme Court appointments and crucially
power to the knesset to overrule Supreme
Court decisions with a simple
parliamentary majority well that
triggered weeks of anti-government
protests and yesterday Benjamin
Netanyahu sacked his defense minister U
of galanta after he called on the prime
minister to temporarily pause the plans
for that judicial reform a sacking which
prompted Mass protests and Strikes Sky's
Middle East correspondent Aleister
bunkel has this report from Jerusalem
in all its 75 years Israel has never
seen a day like this
[Applause]
or by hour through the morning the
protests on the streets grew and the
country quickly started to shut down
flights taking off from the
International Airport were stopped
because staff walked out
major shopping malls closed their doors
and McDonald's shut their restaurants
Nationwide
[Music]
the country's largest trade unions went
on strike and Israel's embassies around
the world shut as diplomatic staff
stayed at home
in Tel Aviv were some of the largest
protests have taken place the city's
mayor announced that there would be no
more municipality Services until further
notice
Israel's political center around the
knesset parliament in Jerusalem was
gridlocked inside and out it's really
scary it's scary to think of this
country possibly going down the road to
dictatorship or theocracy or or some
other implausible idea of what might
happen what do you fear is happening
a war a wall for democracy yes
it might be a turning point the things
that happened in the past few days uh
are they've never happened before look
how many good people that support
democracy support liberalism and
yeah I I think the justice will win
Netanyahu who was out of sight locked in
talks with his Coalition ministers boxed
into a corner of his own making
it's now almost five o'clock in the
afternoon almost six and a half hours
after billion Netanyahu was rumored to
be giving a statement and calling a halt
to the legislation and yet a part of a
short tweet urging for the protest to be
peaceful which they are we've heard
nothing the longer the Prime Minister
remains silent the more they feel that
they had him on the ropes
eventually almost exactly 24 hours after
he sacked his defense minister and
sparked this crisis Netanyahu went on
national television and took aim at
those who oppose him
there is one minority that is willing to
tear this country to Pieces
when there's an opportunity to avoid
Civil War through dialogue I as prime
minister am taking time out for dialogue
this is the first time the government
has given an inch to the pressure of the
protests the decision to pause the
reforms opens a window for the
opposition to negotiate a compromise
but the reforms haven't been halted and
so the protests won't stop the fight for
the future of Israel is not over
Sky News in Jerusalem
more than 130 000 members of the public
and Commercial Services Union have been
urged to walk out in an all-out strike
on the 28th of April the action was
agreed by members today well let's find
out more our chief political
correspondent John Craig joins me now
and certainly hopes that the threat of
strike action had been receding John now
fading because of this well we're
looking at the prospects of a double
whammy of strike misery this summer
that's after the government
believed that things were looking better
with the resolution of the strikes in
the National Health Service but tonight
the PCS have announced that passport
office strike workers will be on strike
for no fewer than six weeks that's right
up to the 6th of May April and May of
course just before the busy holiday
period other per public sector workers
in the PCS dvala staff driving test
National highways and so on 133
000 all and as for the teachers well the
government has made an offer which the
government says is a a fair offer it
says that it is a fair and reasonable
offer a good deal for teachers but the
unions in England the N EU the National
Education Union that's the biggest
teaching union says it's an insulting
offer from a government which simply
doesn't value teachers and it's less
than teachers in Scotland and Wales have
been offered it is a thousand pound
one-off payment for this year 4.5
percent for next year not enough
prospects of more teachers strikes and
the real uh the reality of trikes by
passport office staff during the summer
John in Westminster thank you
Jeremy corbyn is said to be blocked from
standing as a labor candidate at the
next general election
proposed a motion to the party's ruling
body the national executive committee
the committee will vote on the motion
tomorrow or Skies Liz Bates tried to
speak to Mr Corbin earlier this evening
can we just very quickly ask if you're
thinking of standing as an independent
Mr Corbin very much I'm going to the
demonstration against the immigration
bill and I suggest you report that too
we are reporting it it will take 10
seconds
thank you very much I just want to talk
to you in 10 seconds about your futures
thank you very much
the Harper Authority in Dorset has told
Sky news that a full investigation
should be carried out into how 200
barrels of fuel leaked into pool Harbor
yesterday people have been warned to
avoid the water and the beaches in the
area after a major incident was declared
Skies Molina veselinovich has this
report from Dorset
the sheen on the water is clued that
there's fuel on its surface
200 barrels of it leaked into pool
Harbor from an onshore pipeline The
Spill contained by these floating
barriers part of a major operation to
try to limit the pollution we've got
helicopters we've got drones we've got
foot patrols as well in order to collect
as much information and data and feed
that back to the emergency control
center here at pool Harbor how serious
is it it's not as serious as we
initially feared but I do think it's a
full investigation should be carried out
to ensure that we understand how this
event took place and to make sure that
steps are put in place to prevent it
happening again the company which runs
the oil field to perenco says the
situation is now under control but there
are concerns about the impact on the
wildlife here pool Harbor is a nature
conservation site one of Europe's
largest natural harbors and home to
vibrant bird and marine life and while
authorities say The Spill is reducing
it's clear the threat is not over yet
pool Harbor here behind me would usually
be packed with people paddle boarding
doing water sports but the public has
been told to stay out of the water and
if they come into contact with a spill
they should wash with soap and water
those who live here want answers about
what the consequences will be a lot of
people have been worried about drilling
going on here over the years anyway but
they've got a duty of care to look after
a naturally beautiful area all the
businesses that rely on it are going to
lose vast amounts of money because
nobody's allowed into the harbor wants
to take the risk we do a lot of water
sports we've got a couple of boats that
we use and the harbor is our life so yes
obviously very upset
they tell us there's going to be no
lasting damage I hope they're right
the cause of the league is still unknown
but an investigation is underway to
determine how a fuel spill could happen
in this most delicate of ecosystems
Sky News pool
a reconstruction has been shown in the
case against Gwyneth Paltrow tonight the
man who is suing the actress for three
hundred thousand dollars described the
moment he heard a blood curdling scream
before the crash Skies Rachel venables
reports
called the Hollywood star has already
given her side of events to the court in
Park City Utah claiming she was the real
victim in that crash on the ski slopes
in 2016.
but today it was retired optometrist
Terry sanderson's turn to take to the
stand and he had a very different story
of who was at fault
I just remember everything was great and
then I heard something I've never heard
of the ski resort and that was a blood
curdling scream
just I can't do it it was
and then
boom
he says the crash with Gwyneth Paltrow
had a huge impact on his health and life
including the end of his relationship I
knew she
didn't buy into this she didn't buy in
to me not being the same person and
coming
into a relationship and
and I said I'm not sure I'm going to get
to back to normal again after the crash
with the oscar-winning actress he sends
an email to his daughter titled I'm
famous in cross-questioning he called
that misguided did you think it was cool
to collide with a celebrity absolutely
not
that is not who I am no do you ever
write that
ever tell anybody that I don't think it
came out in those words but I don't
remember that but
I
I think I was trying to communicate to
my kids with the end of Terry
sanderson's evidence the defense now
begins their case starting with ski
instructor Eric Christensen he'd been
teaching Paltrow some that day and who
denied he yelled at Mr Sanderson
where you were bullied to Mr Sanderson I
was not
is that a ridiculous claim I I feel that
it is yes Terry Sanderson is seeking
damages of a minimum of three hundred
thousand dollars while Gwyneth Paltrow's
counterclaim is for one dollar Rachel
venables Sky News
well that was let's go News at 10 coming
up we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press preview
including this story on the front page
of the eye the headline s p turmoil
delays the dream of an independent
Scotland well tonight we're joined by
the political editors of the guardian
and the Sun papakura and Harry Cole back
in just a moment
[Music]
foreign